a lot of people have heard the term your
network is your net worth to a degree
that's true to the other degree that's
the average of the five people you spend
the most time with well it's not true
for bill gates and for jeff bezos
because the people that they spend time
with are less than their net worth which
would mean that their net would be less
than that and so you know there are
statements that are thrown around
frequently that don't have necessarily a
lot of evidence but you know are i would
say spiritually correct and so what i
want to talk about today and for those
who don't know me my name is alex for
mosey i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies
over 100 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you and i make these
videos because i just love getting troll
comments about being in my mom's
basement this is not this is actually
just a closet cause i just like having
no windows and i wear the things that
i'm comfortable in that being said in
the last year i would say that i fell
out of touch with the last two friends
that i had from high school and or
college and this has been a process
that's happened you know gradually over
time and i was having a conversation
with dean graziosi who has become a very
very close friend of mine and i brought
the topic up with him and i thought the
discussion would be worth sharing and so
one of the things that he told me early
on in our relationship which really
really gave me a lot of pause was the
cost of his dreams and so i asked him
earlier on and it was about 18 months
ago before layla and i decided to build
kind of our personal brands etc about
you know the cost of fame and he said
yeah you know i've got people who show
up at my house and people who leave
weird mean comments and he's like all
the time the thing is is that that is a
price i'm willing to pay to make the
impact that i want to make with my life
when he said that it just it really
struck me because
to me it was in a lot of ways you know
selfish to kind of not spread the
message out of fear of what it would
cost me that being said there's
obviously pros that you know you know
we've made whatever decision that they
outweigh the cons but it was just an
interesting perspective in terms of just
it is a price that he was willing to pay
and so i want to lead this discussion
towards the friend conversation that had
with him and he had said that he
recently had lost one of his last
friends the last friend that he had had
from kind of his childhood and i think
that there's a lot of people who are
like you know never forget where you
come from and the people who supported
you et cetera and i think that's true
but i think for the vast majority of us
a lot of people don't support us on our
way up at least it felt that way for me
what's interesting is that a lot of
people root for you until you do better
than them and they stop rooting for you
and i'm not saying that the the people
um that i'm talking about were like that
but it's just that was like the first
wave of friends that i lost and it was
just because they didn't actually want
to see me win and i had a quote uh the
other day that went pretty viral on
twitter which was real friends talk [ __ ]
to your face and praise you behind your
back and fake friends do the opposite
and when i say talk [ __ ] i mean like
bullshitting you know what i mean like
give each other you know give each other
flack if i'm giving someone flack they
know that we're homies you know dr cashy
i was i was i was thinking about
patenting uh the hormozy advertising
cycles i spent so long developing the
cycle which is going to be in one of the
books that comes up you know in the
future and his comment was get over
yourself and that's what i and that's
exactly what i want from a friend right
i want somebody who's going to say that
rather than be like oh that's cool and
then be like i can't believe this guy
and so
we have these people that we collect you
know throughout our lives and sometimes
that come in you know you've probably
heard the saying they're here for a
season a reason or a lifetime and i
think you know for me a lot of people
have been seasonal and so i wanted to
share that because i know that i'm sure
some of you have had a similar path to
me in that i didn't have a tremendous
amount of support from my parents i
think they now retroactively think they
supported me because it's much easier
that way but i did not i did not have
any support from my parents for the
decisions that i took until it was
already beyond obvious that i was going
to be successful and that took years and
that was very hard for me at the time i
think friends fell in that same category
and so when i was having this discussion
with dean we we dove into this a little
bit more but as we you know ascend
towards our goals and i don't say a send
in a literal sense in terms of like
socioeconomic status or whatever but
just like we move closer towards we want
to where we want to go and our vision
and our mission and our lives become
clear it also becomes clear when you
have contrast with people from your past
and i have several rules of thumb that
are i begin to develop around these
relationships one of them is if i can
only talk about the past with someone
they usually aren't good friends of mine
because i don't really live in the past
i live in the future i live in where i
want to go what i want to do the things
that i find interesting or the present
of the things that i find interesting
today or right now top of mind and if i
can't talk about those things with
somebody then our friendship kind of by
its very nature will decline over time
because there is no growth right because
it's only in the past and i have felt a
tremendous amount of guilt around the
loss of those relationships but i also
felt a guilt of carrying them on as in i
felt like i needed to water these plants
out of necessity rather than out of you
know some sort of exchange now some
people might decry that or speak against
the idea of having an exchange but i
don't think that's realistic i think
that people stay in relationships
because there is an exchange of value
that occurs now i think the difference
is the strength or depth of the
relationship is how long you are willing
to wait for the exchange to occur so a
parent for example is willing to wait a
very long time for a positive exchange
from a child coming back to them right
now and some people could make the
argument that you know children are a
gift throughout that entire period of
time and that's awesome and that's a
perspective whatever but just to use the
time frame as a nice thinking process if
you just met someone if you don't feel
like there's you know a huge benefit to
to to knowing them you know within the
immediate future you probably don't
really pursue them out and the longer
you have had positive exchanges the
longer you are willing to wait for the
next one right it's it's intermittent
reinforcement from a behavior standpoint
right like we are literally reinforced
in this relationship and the way that
addiction works is the same thing right
like you immediately get positive hits
and then you can start extending how
long before you get another positive hit
which is also how abusive relationships
work right like abuse abuse positive
abuse positive positive pause and then
like abuse and then positive is a little
bit later and then a little bit later
until the point where there's almost no
positive whatsoever i'm not saying
that's how you should run relationships
but more so how we work as humans the
point of me breaking this down is that i
have lost a lot of the friends or almost
all of the friends that i had when i
started my journey and the upside is
people will come into your life to fill
the vacuum that the other people left
but sometimes it doesn't happen
immediately and i think getting
comfortable with having space is a good
thing and a lot of people have the
impulse or urge to always have people
around them and i think it's to their
own detriment because i think if you can
spend time alone with your thoughts and
be okay with just being you without
other people then you are more selective
and it's the same way with dating some
people can't be alone some people can't
be without a significant other and so
they just end up chatting up with the
first person they see after they become
single again right and it's because they
have a fear of being alone more than
they hold a they have an aligned mission
with someone that they think that this
person is really the best pick and so
a lot of ways are similar to dating with
friends in that we can hold out uh and
really just pick the best people and i
think that
you know if we at least for me if i have
two or three good friends i'm i'm more
than satisfied my cup is very full but i
think where i feel drained is where i
feel like i have lots and lots and lots
of acquaintances that are transactional
in nature
but purely transactional or at least
they have a much shorter time horizon
for the transactions to occur and so i
sell this to say if you have lost
friends during the process of the climb
i don't think it is something that you
should lament or be upset about i think
that it is a sign of growth because a
lot of people say hey you've changed and
the only natural response that i can
have to that is
you have it and i think that that's kind
of sums up the entirety of this of this
video which is if you grow you change
some people most people don't like
change especially if they themselves
have not grown or changed and or if they
have grown in a different direction from
you and it is natural for us to not want
to continue relationships with people
that have grown or have values that are
too far in contrast to our own in those
contract those values can change over
time and that's okay and so i think that
for me it took me a really long time to
navigate through this and it was kind of
an emotionally explorative experience to
just say
that's okay
and
is this price something that i'm willing
to pay
and
for me it's a resounding yes i would be
far more sad that i had not realized my
potential or what i hope to accomplish
in my life in exchange for
relationships that that i sacrificed in
order
sacrificed my dreams in order to
maintain now that being said it almost
appears as though i'm sacrificing all
relationships in order to have the dream
and that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that you will sacrifice old
relationships and you will create room
for new ones and so i think that there
is this i don't know old wives tale or a
societal expectation that if someone
sheds friends for lack of a better term
or loses friends or friends you know
dissipate into the distance over time
that they are
a non-constant person and i think that
the answer to that question is yes we
grow
and unless the friends you have are
growing with you and are pushing you to
grow then they are probably not friends
who will stay with you for the long haul
and so for me i'll leave with this kind
of last thing that i think about for the
people that i want to be friends with i
want
friends who root for me behind my back
and that is rare most people do not root
for you behind your back it is sad that
there are more strangers on the internet
who root for me than people who knew me
from back home and it's because we had a
shared context at home and the
discrepancy between where you are and
where they are over time they
personalize the fact that they are not
with you because they had the same
resources at the same beginning and so
you're in a different place as a result
of your own decisions and so as a result
they feel bad and they don't like that
and you're a reminder of that what i
seek from the friends that i have um are
one that they genuinely are rooting for
me and that is evidenced by them rooting
for me behind my back i also hope that
they talk [ __ ] to my face because that
is what makes life worth living uh for
me but i hope
to admire them
i want to strive to be more like my
friends in certain ways and i hope that
they raise the bar for me to be better
and be better in the ways that i want to
be better and so
in that way picking friends who are
people who are further ahead of you
doesn't have to be financially it can
just be it can be in marriage it can be
physically it can be whatever and then
the hope is that you are better in some
ways than they are and then they can
grow from you in that way and in that
way you both get better and then you
have a an extended exchange that
continues directionally towards both of
your goals my definitions and my view on
friendship has changed over time it
probably will continue to develop and
refine but i mean this because i have a
lot of people who message me and are
like hey i feel really alone right now i
don't feel like a lot of people are
supporting me and i make this video say
that's okay and i think that there are
seasons and
at the end of a season when you have a
vacuum someone does step in to fill it
and i can promise you that if you have a
higher standard and you wait and you
don't just give of yourself for no
reason just because you are afraid to be
alone or be without friends
you will end up with better friends who
actually root for you and are not just
place fillers or false friends who you
know smile to your face but stab you
behind your back or actually talk down
on you and so i think if you can have
that bar and you can have that tolerance
you can give yourself that space and
that permission to say i've lost a
friend and that's okay and i still love
them as a human even if i can't give the
time that i once did because it doesn't
make sense for me anymore because we've
grown apart and that's okay and so i've
given myself that permission to say
these are the prices that i'm willing to
pay to grow into the person that i want
to be
and that's okay and so mosey nation i
love you all the road can be can be
arduous but i i think the road itself is
the reason we do it because of the
person that we hope to become and the
process of becoming which is the
successes i've defined it is the process
of becoming and the process of striving
is the success and so anyways my friends
keeping awesome i love you all i'll see
you guys in the next vid bye